here's the crazy thing about you and i
don't think most people realize this or
know this about you
but art was always your thing not comedy
you were so good at art that you started
selling
uh your art on t-shirts in the street
and i've heard the story tommy
hilfiger's son finds these t-shirts
spike lee saw the t-shirts and said hey
dude here's my
card call me yeah it's true
yeah it's how do you know this stuff
that's crazy yeah no that actually
happened yeah yeah
and you don't call that's that's odd to
me why don't you call spike lee and say
when you're a struggling artist what do
you have in mind mr lee
i i think it was uh self-esteem as as an
artist i didn't think even like right
now when you're like
oh you have to be pretty good i'm like
yeah i don't think so but um
yeah even then it kind of felt like art
art never felt
natural to me it was something that i
liked to do and i knew it was
i was close to it but it wasn't until i
tried stand up that i was like oh i
speak this language
you know like wait a second what kind of
art were you doing michael what were you
i was doing a lot of i would do like a
lot of portraits and a lot of kind of
i guess you would call it i guess would
be like pop art you know like kind of
right stuff like that but um
it wasn't good to me it was hack it was
like it's
it's art that anybody would do yeah but
but for me mom
but for tommy hilfiger's son to look at
your art
and he brings it to his dad tommy
hilfiger sees your art and says
michael che i want to give you a job i'm
going to give you an
office in my corporation i want you to
come and go as you please and create art
for my brand for tommy hilfiger
that is mind-blowing stuff how old were
you when that happened
oh man 22 22
and you go [ __ ] this it's too corporate
i don't feel good in this but i i would
have liked to find my place and for
somebody like tommy hilfiger
that's a big deal and you walk away from
it
it it's crazy now that i'm 38 or 37 but
uh then as a kid you don't know you
think
you think opportunities come you know
you have zero
yeah you kind of do you're just like you
you think you have you think you have
nothing but time
i think you don't really realize what a
luxury you have being young
and um and also i was just like not
ready and i was like i'll wait like this
isn't right
i'm not good i gotta figure out
something that's good
and um and i just passed on a lot of
stuff man and
that's so crazy that you know what's so
even funny is like i know
spike now and i don't think spike knows
this
really yeah like it's not like i saw it
was that long ago so i think like if if
spike
hears this now he's gonna be like what
like he's not even gonna know
that this actually happened like he's
never said oh wait a second
haven't i met you somewhere before he
didn't he he he has no clue
he has no clue and by the way when you
when you quit tommy hilfiger
you didn't even say goodbye to tommy
hilfiger you didn't thank him for the
job you just left you just said
this is wrong yeah dude you ghosted man
have you ever run into tommy hilfiger
since uh
yeah actually i actually just talked to
him like a couple months ago and we were
laughing about it
uh he's he's a great guy man he was he
was so nice man he took me
he took me up to his office and took me
to every station was like this is
michael che
and he's going to be a star like he was
just the nicest guy
and i was like what is it i thought he
was crazy honestly
maybe he's trying to maybe not he's
running a scam on you or something
yeah this can't be the accident
it's too nice
you